I think I was depressed long before I
was famous I think I was anxious long
before I ever even moved to LA well duh
so good to see you virtually yeah how
are you doing right now with everything
kind of going on how are you feeling
about everything how is life right now I
always feel like when I see you I'm like
let's talk about it if you like my
interviews if you are the most like
emotive good yeah you like it's pretty
it's a it's a weird time for everybody I
feel like it's pretty up and down for
everybody today I feel fine
you know I feel like it's a day-to-day
experience like I think two days ago I
had like a massive breakdown and I was
like humans are meant to be cooped up
you know I mean I feel like this is like
an ultimate experience of like you can't
really distract yourself from yourself
so I think that that affects everybody
differently yeah a lot of ups and a lot
of downs but I think it's making all of
us feel more present and kind of like in
touch with ourselves and in touch with
loved ones cuz you're forced to
communicate from like a distance and
FaceTime and zoom and it's weird it's a
weird time for sure where are you right
now and who are you with I'm in my house
yeah my boyfriend is is here we're
quarantine and we live together so
reports Union together and our two cats
[Music]
song is called remember me so I just
want to know what do you want people to
remember and to know about you most I
mean I guess I just I would love it I
would love to communicate to people more
of a sense let less of like an image of
me and more of a sense of connection
between me and them I think I think I
just would love to encourage people I
don't need that I don't need anybody to
see me in a certain way I just would
love to encourage people to delve into
like the Messier sides of themselves and
connect with themselves so that they can
connect with everyone around them and
have a better like human experience in
human life I feel like you're very big
on that and like sharing the messy sides
of you and like the complexities of
human life and you posted this thing on
Instagram and I think it was like you
crying and talking about how you're
having FaceTime sessions and trauma
therapy and you're trying to write more
what was kind of going through your head
when you wrote that and why was it
important for you why is it important
for you to share I don't know if you
feel this as a person but do you ever
feel like there's like do you ever feel
a wheat like a visceral feeling of
balance yeah in in daily life or in like
and you observe something like even when
you watch a movie and you're like
something's off about this it doesn't
feel balanced like there's just like a
kind of a thing and when things are like
us they should be humans feel that by
the way yeah I know it's just hard to
like yeah and I don't really know how
I'm gonna say this without something so
stupid but like sometimes I go on like
my social media feed and I go through it
and I'm like oh it makes me feel like
sick like it makes me feel like we're
leaning so hard into like a sort of like
a heightened version of our lives like I
don't know how to describe it cuz
there's nothing wrong with it listen I'm
like the first person to post BTS from a
photoshoot or from something I'm doing
that may seem like the way but it's like
real right it's kind of laughs it's like
the highest version of myself that I
feel comfortable showing you but it's
not technically yeah and okay I think we
also have this like cultural disease
where we're always encouraged to show
it's the most positive aspects of our
mood of ourselves of our life and like
frame it in that way and I noticed that
growing up you know it's always like how
are you and you're like good like can I
can can I honestly say that I'm good and
if I can I will say it and it's not I'll
say I'm fine you know it's like it's
always a very we put this kind of like
glaze over everything because we're like
so afraid of the darker side of life and
so we just like avoid it at all costs
and I if I if I look at that for too
long or if I like spend too long doing
that myself because I do it too I'm not
like shaming anyone I do it too um I
start to feel really like almost like
I've eaten too much of one thing I'm
like I'm so sick of this I can't do this
anymore
and then I need to like balance it by
being like this is the God's honest
truth this is what's happening right now
I sometimes I cry so much I make myself
sick like I'm so up and down this is the
honest you know full scope of like my
life experience right now and I know
that that's not singular to me I know
that that's like a really common thing
you know I think if we really were more
attuned to what's going on inside us and
we felt more comfortable expressing it
so many people would be better off and
if I can with my like weirdly big
platform that I don't like feel attached
to or related to I'm always like I don't
understand why it's there but if it's
there I'm going to attempt to use it for
stuff like this because like if I was
younger and I saw somebody being like
I'm not okay I'd be like oh so maybe I
cannot be okay and then I wouldn't have
had like years of being like I'm fine
you know well I think but I think you
kind of hit the nail on the head and it
is so important to talk about right
whether it be depression or anxiety and
I think a lot of younger celebrities
have been talking about that more and
it's kind of taking the stigma away I
mean Billie Eilish talked about being
suicidal Selena Gomez just said that
she's been bipolar do you think that
there's something within Hollywood
that contributes to those issues or do
you think it's like a really worldwide
doesn't matter if you're in Hollywood
doesn't matter if you're just a kid
going to school do you have anything to
say about just like those correlations
yeah I think I think both of them are
valid I think I was depressed long
before I was famous I think I was
anxious long before I ever even moved to
LA I think that they obviously exist
everywhere I do
also though think that our culture is
perpetuating it in the sense that our
our culture and our society as it is now
as we just like have accepted it I think
that our society is set up almost to
make us feel it's it's not it's not what
we're meant to be dealing with day to
day and that's why so many people are
like oh I feel so much better in nature
or I feel great taking a week off
I feel great like oh I just when I drink
water I feel so much better it's like
when we do two things that are that are
meant for a human body and a human mind
and you know spirit and experience
obviously those things are much more in
line with our bodies and then what we're
doing now and so I think that that's
cultural I think that that's widespread
I think that nobody can escape that and
yeah I do think that celebrity culture
is incredibly toxic in the sense that um
I think celebrities feel pressure to be
perfect and then everybody watching
celebrities feels pressure to be like
them and then because people praise you
for that you're always just like okay
how could I be better how could I be
more perfect how could I be you know
more how can I reach more people and you
slow down and you're like why do I want
that I don't know if I want that like I
feel like what do I need right now what
is best for me how do I redesign my
opinion of what is beautiful to me and
escape sort of everybody else's idea of
what it is because we grow up in that
right so like you reach like the age of
16 and you already feel like you want to
fast forward to when you're 25 and
you've got it all together and like you
just you miss everything because we it's
nobody it's nobody's fault right it's
just like how it is right now and so all
that we can really do is talk about ways
to free people from like
expectations and overblown ideas of what
happiness and beauty and success is and
also allow ourselves those things to be
human because I never want to be in a
position where I'm not allowed to
explore that as well I want to pretend
like I have it all together because I
definitely don't but I do I do find it
important to talk about if you have a
platform yeah what is your relationship
like with social media right now because
I think we have a lot of time on our
hands it's a lot easier to read comments
it's a lot easier to scroll your feeds
how do you feel about it right now I
know you did take a break for a couple
of days yeah I actually I took a break
for like three weeks when I was doing my
last movie which is a very short amount
of time but it feels like a long amount
of time when you know when everybody
else is on social media um I have I mean
it's I don't know it's such a massive
entity I think it would be hard to be
like this it's one thing but I think
that um I think that it's good to take a
break because it isn't real life I don't
think that it's evil I think that it
really helps us especially right now
it's like wow what a unique experience
to be able to communicate with people
while we're on a global lockdown we
couldn't do that without a key and
without technology really magic like
true modern-day magic and at the same
time nothing is just one thing like it
can be great and also poisonous at a
certain extent to a certain extent it
can be a negative thing and then also
something you really dabble in and enjoy
in a couple days right like I feel like
people are always like you said this but
then you said that but it's really it's
it's your own experience of it that you
need to learn how to tap into and
moderate because nobody can tell you
what your limits are but it's it's not a
never-ending well of love and enjoyment
I think it can be quite sidious and so
so yeah I think I think it has its place
and I think right now we're really
grateful for it and you just need to
learn what your limits are well we are
getting wraps so I just want to ask a
couple of things hey how is quarantine
and going with Thomas we know that he
recently accepted a
the new Gossip Girl reboot how excited
are you for him how excited is he and do
you feel like this is kind of bringing
you guys almost closer in a way oh yeah
I mean out first of all so excited so
proud I'm a massive fan of the original
series so it's like so bizarre right
that like you grew up watching and
you're like oh my god Chuck Bass me and
then your boyfriend's like I go out you
know very silly very weird life so proud
of him it's gonna be so exciting yeah I
can't wait to be you know visiting New
York or like spending time there is our
favorite city yeah we're amazing I mean
like it's it's we're really compatible
so it's great to be together
of course like everybody needs their
space and we just moved into his life we
just moved into a studio loft and so
it's like one long room and we were like
that's fine like we're never we're never
really in our apartment anyway you know
of course yeah yeah I know we're just
we're we've got like our systems I make
breakfast and lunch she makes dinner and
yeah we spent a lot of time together we
spend some time alone we're great we're
just like we're so like when it's right
it's right you know yeah abcdefg
actually know you're tic TOCs are
amazing and I already saw that there's
like a remember be dance challenge so
what inspires your tic TOCs was how the
kardashian ones they were hilarious yeah
I just love things that make me laugh
um I feel like I'm I'm so I love I love
to laugh I mean everyone's left but like
I'm such a comedy person and people
don't really like know that I don't like
to talk about that but I'm so i'm a
comedy geek i love to do comedy anything
i just laugh all the time he makes me
laugh all the time we just do like skits
all day long we're so stupid same thing
with my best friend like all we do is
just like stupid stupid stuff that make
each other laugh and so yeah anything
that makes me laugh I have a hard time
imagining I'm gonna really get into the
dances I'm gonna try to do the remember
me dance cuz it's like so cute people
already have yeah you have to do it I'll
try you and my label or both like you
have to do it yeah I'll work on it
I'll eat I'll leave it to the real the
real dancers but it's yeah it's really
it's really sweet to already have that
because it's like such a cultural
phenomenon in and of itself so yeah do
you have a message of hope right now
chip everyone kind of going through this
difficult time yeah I think that this is
such a singular time and I think that
this is a very trying time and and
whether you you know it there's sort of
like two things that are going on right
now there's the pandemic which requires
immediate attention constant compassion
stay in your house like practice empathy
I know it's difficult I know you're
gonna feel stir-crazy but you have to be
if you have any like discipline left you
have to use all of it and use all of
your empathy that I know we all have and
just like combine it and stay in your
house don't leave for anything unless
it's absolutely essential but all we can
do right now as with all things that are
happening that you know this this
pandemic is somewhat like a natural
disaster it's happening right and all we
can do is respond and do what we can and
do everything that we can and I know
that I'm doing that and I really hope
that you're doing that and after that
all you can do is take care of yourself
and it's so important to stay in touch
with yourself journal and talk openly
about mental health and if you don't
know how to do that yet right now is a
great time to learn find someone who you
trust who you can communicate with
hopefully in your house and if not
that's why we have our phones yeah stay
strong definitely hold onto hope because
um there's only so much we can do and
and we are all experiencing this
together which is kind of like a small
bit of magic that we can hang on to
[Music]